so this time
because i don't trust my senses i'm
going to do this in the reverse order
we're going to go first principles
first
and then we're going to draw ourselves a
picture you always must ask the question
when you get a result like this right
well what does it mean and as you will
notice there's actually something
important a sort of um
what's the word i'm looking for like
almost a disclaimer that you need to
make after you go through first
principles because something first
principles won't necessarily tell you so
let's give this a go
if this is the function right
then it's derivative by definition is
the limit
as h approaches zero of and off you go
you start reciting right so this is f f
of x plus h right
here's f of x
and then of course you divide by h
because that's the run okay now you're
not used to this all that much because
you're like what i do with this you know
i could expand brackets i could add
fractions
okay now that's all right so that's
they're notoriously anti-social but that
doesn't mean you can't work with them
right we're used to rationalizing
denominators so on the top no problem
just rationalize the numerator right
what am i going to need to multiply
x plus h plus now this guy you might
remember has a name starts with c
do you remember long word
uh oh so close so close
these two guys these two guys are called
conjugates of each other conjugates
conjugates come up again and again
and again
when we get to complex numbers at the
end of the year conjugates will reappear
fantastically useful
so the reason why we can use conjugates
here is because
you're going to get difference of
squares up here at the top right this is
really
and a minus b times a plus b situation
so once you expand difference of squares
you get
well you get the difference of two
squares a squared minus b squared right
so i've got my limit
and here's a so a squared will be this
right
that's that's a squared
take away
b squared right
that's b squared a squared minus b
squared i'm done that's the crucial step
now i do have all of this
garbage over here on the bottom
but that's okay that's okay he'll come
out in the wash right so now
and you're starting to get the trend
right in order to evaluate first
principles you're always getting
something on the numerator that's going
to dance with this h on the denominator
right if you don't then something is
going wrong in your algebra but here
we're okay x and negative x go
the h's go
right so really all i have is this
yep
now i can actually evaluate
like so
so i've got two of those
okay now let's just check this out let's
just check this out because we have a
rule let's see if the rule can handle
not just negative indices but fractional
indices if we replay
right how do you rewrite root x in terms
of powers
x x to the half right
x
so all i need to do is bring that power
out the front
and reduce the power by one
yeah
which sure enough that means you're
gonna go on the denominator right to
reduce ooh that was easy okay now
what is this meaning what's this thing
look like
okay so
here is my um
set of axes you can see i've only got i
actually don't even need that i only
need that okay
what's the square root of x look like
it's half of a sideways parabola yep
half the sideways parabola there is the
square root of x
what's one on two root x what does that
thing look like
like is it an asymptote isn't there
yeah because
number one i i actually have two
asymptotes just like earlier first you
can't put in x equals zero there can you
because on the denominator right so
i'll just leave it i've got this guy
at x equals zero right but on a not only
that as i put increasing numbers like as
x approaches infinity right over here
the denominator is well it's not exactly
skyrocketing because it's the square
root of x so it slows down but it's
still getting bigger forever right so b
that it gets bigger forever it's going
to approach zero right so there's my
horizontal asymptote in there
and in order to fit into these two
things that's pretty much all you can do
it's like if you find the line
it sounds like there aren't any ways
yeah i guess so i guess so except you
would have to then if you have the
square you'd have to restrict the range
but that would be fine there you go
that's that's what it would be because
you'd don't yeah you get this other side
over here
does it match what you expected
kind of because it's like it's like
yeah so this graph right the original
one squared x it is let's think about
its gradient think about its gradient
it's increasing all the time right it
slows down it slows down forever in fact
but never slows down so much that it
turns around
okay that it turns around now one of the
ways you can know that is because to
turn around this gradient would have to
at some point equal zero do you agree
with that right but there's no value of
x you can ever put in here to make the
whole thing equal zero you can get very
very very small but you'll never
actually get to zero right which is why
the square root of x never turns around
it's positive this remains positive it
checks out that's all there is to it
okay